yeah wait tell us what's on the other
side
uh more caves oh hi
oh good oh i'm falling
oh my god no he can't kick while he's
burning i think
don't be afraid just believe don't be
afraid just believe
are we leaving the cave right now i
think so actually yeah
this is yeah we're out does anybody know
where the key card is
guys yeah this rope is
hot tall jesus this place is [ __ ] big
i can see why that dude died from
climbing yeah
he looked at this rope and was like ah
screw it i'm here
hey do we need to go back in the other
entrance though and go blow the dudes
well i don't want to
okay is there something important we
need from there because we didn't get
anything important did we
we made it a grand total of no distance
where
are we supposed to be we're on the coast
we're on the coast oh yeah look the
ocean's over here by me
oh wow well then where oh we were
supposed to get a key card i don't
remember where
key card is um i need to blow
more there was a lot of dynamite we only
blew one why is there a spotlight
oh hey bud okay that was weird
i hear that yeah i hear that well we
know that they can drown
so that's always an option oh yeah
that's a lot of dudes careful
oh he lit himself on fire that's kind of
sad
oh he's coming and he's coming he's
coming
you miss me
one of them is throwing fire bob you're
on fire i'm fine this is fine
wait you're on fire check me out i feel
kind of burning
cutting still on firewood i am
this guy's so tough and he's dead and
you're dead
i need a campfire you need a campfire
i need heat you need heat i can't help
you with that
warm my loins uh
i'll think about it i'm gonna look up
quickly where the key card is
because i don't trust anybody to tell me
so i'm gonna go look at myself oh it's
near where we are
center left side of the map okay hey
look a shipping container
where you see one over here you see the
shipping containers in the distance no i
don't oh
oh that's what that is there's some
pretty cavey looking stuff up here
yeah on my map that says there's a cave
to the left there
but i'm just going to check out what the
shipping containers have if anything
good
let me know if there's anything you
break the boxes or stuff in these
cardboard boxes
um there's a story item in here but it
it's just a random ass shipping manifest
i don't know if it's too important
about the one in the water turtles
there's turtles here
getting them they're really slow
[ __ ] those guys i want to drink their
blood i'm trying
good do it oh [ __ ]
they're coming oh my god okay i got one
of them
man this one's tough okay it's not tough
anymore yeah i'm not seeing anything
else besides random electronic parts so
i think we just go to the cave
was the cave up this way yeah you're
going right it's at the rocks you're
going right through that cool cool
tight about the episode the episode we
just recorded probably won't be going
out next week we gotta still get it
edited and stuff
yeah we're ahead a bit but that's okay
you might see this one by 2023 if you're
lucky yeah
i guess you'll just have to follow on
your favorite podcast place to know when
we upload our our weekly podcast
distractible.podcast slash calm
yep oh this seems kind of ominous
i like the whooshing the whooshing is
cool okay there's a drop off to the
right
that might be the lawyer cave yeah
oh that's oh bob i didn't know you went
to the left i just saw your name
disappeared so it was just your face
creeping around a [ __ ] corner
oh this guy's down here well this is not
necessarily the lawyer cave but there's
no guys down here
only the strongest man alive yeah i
don't think that there's anything down
here
it looks kind of uh kind of dead endish
and doesn't necessarily
looks like it's dynamitable i've only
got one dynamite left i think maybe i
should save that
well there was a whole there was a
boatload of dynamite we passed by in the
last cave
yeah then i used some i i used one of
the sticks but we can only hold two at a
time i think
i thought three three yeah
yeah okay anyway i'm coming back from
this one i don't think
there's anything down here but maybe
there is
i'm coming guys wait for me
try and bait him over here wayne you
guys fighting somebody
you need help from the strongest man
alive there goes one
oh god you didn't tell me about the bat
what the
look i did it was just a long time ago i
think my fire
went through the rocks that's not good
man they are quick
i do not like you burning you burning
these boys are we doing this
um it's going to be tough catching them
all right a month where they kind of
walk through okay got one oh both of
them they're both on fire
going down i'm down as well apparently
one's down i'm taking
[Music]
where's wade i'm right he's behind you
but i can't like get in without hitting
you guys probably uh maybe i'm out of
stamina
there oh thank god there we go that's
the death
that's good stuff that's good stuff let
me see
uh yeah so this is going to curve around
i think we go through that blockade and
then it curves up to the right
okay we don't we don't want to go down
to the left no no no the lawyer's cave
looks like it's up to the
top of this path here okay no
i'm wrong wait what the hell no no i'm
right
that's correct yeah that's where we need
to go i think
wait okay because there's a big bed down
there i don't like yeah not that way
definitely yeah
you're going the right way i think oh
that i really don't understand what
you're talking about there are so many
things crawling down there in the
distance
oh yeah oh my god that's so many bodies
oh
careful wait wait careful wait careful
there's something
literally right there oh i see it it
looks oh my god it looks awful
are you trying to let it try and i'm
good bye bob i'm down here okay hold on
you will be missed
i'm climbing i'm climbing back up
it's standing still i'm trying to light
it but it's okay don't move don't move
don't move and move
got you [ __ ] i can't believe i didn't
just die
i'm just going to throw down hit a baby
don't push me off i won't push you off
you don't push me off
i won't push anybody off dynamite i'm
game
yeah one second i'm just making more
more molotovs because i it kind of stays
still when you burn it so i'm gonna try
to bro okay
that one didn't seem to work
i'm sorry oh my god i'm gonna die oh my
god i'm sorry why don't i put this out
how do i write this wrong
i can't right this round it's too late
[Laughter]
we would have time to run then okay i'm
throwing the dynamite
oh my god
how are you still alive geez this guy's
too tough bam this guy's so
tough why is my fire go through the
ground sometimes
i don't know get him
i didn't light it you literally just
threw a bottle of licorice
just i don't know i went through the
ground you're right what the hell
all right i'm gonna go slice him up
oh god he's on fire oh my god oh my god
that hurts so bad oh never mind this was
a terrible idea i'm here
i'm blocking i'm thinking i'm thinking
oh i don't come down after all
i'm just bodyblocking you right now
she's
up okay taking medicine oh oh he got me
he broke my block
jesus okay oh god ow oh my god okay
oh my god oh jesus right through my
block
this guy is really tough okay i'm just
going to climb back up the rope and
maybe we go from our bomb
everything's fine you're up i'm up i'm
up i'm up where's the rope where's the
rope
climbing right here where i'm at where
oh god let me up oh
i've never climbed in my life oh my god
hey look i got a thing
wait a camcorder guys right down here
okay good
we could yeah i guess we could run and
try to get what we need and get out of
there
oh good i got it i got the key card the
key card's right here
okay dude only one of us needs a key
card right i'm sure i have some kind of
ranged
weapon
[Music]
i saw the clean ark from you to wait
good job guys man there's a lot of
bodies down here
yeah they're really gross why is this
the lawyer's cave
okay got the key card
uh because this is all the people that
all you're stepped on to get their jobs
and money you're right you're right
you're right
okay so as far as i know this
goes to like some boat door or something
i think oh the boat yeah yeah the the
boats out in the sea
maybe even near the shipping containers
there was a boat we went to a long time
ago
and there's like a locked door we have
to have like a yeah this must be to that
i don't know what's behind the door
congratulations we did a great job there
teamwork and our friendship won the day
only two of us almost killed all of us
wait it wasn't even you for once
it wasn't me at all i didn't almost kill
all of us i saved you guys both went
down i saved your asses and you threw
dynamite at me this is true
okay wait the key card is not for the
boat is what i'm hearing
oh okay well it's not for the boat
there's a code we need for the boat or
something
there's something locked on the boat
they didn't say what it was for which
would have been very informative they
just go like
it's not the boat wink wink wink wink
wait do we can we look at the key card
somewhere here it is yeah i'm looking
use on door
oh here we go found it
maybe we gotta type in group chat use on
door and it'll be like some kind of
adventure
that'll be perfect i think if we all get
on the radio and just
chant use on door use on door
what button is that cue what is it this
button oh
cue use a door
what the [ __ ] i don't like that i don't
like that at all
yeah why i'm stuck why i stuck i want to
wash
blood off wait where wait
oh you guys are outside the cave i'm
just a [ __ ] it's fine
oh it's gonna say what's wrong hey
friends
oh my god right
okay so it's apparently in the sinkhole
there's a door oh good let's find the
door
do you remember what cave got you down
in the sinkhole
no all
[Music]
oh it's fine calm down so dramatic
hi sorry to interrupt but i just wanted
to let you know about our new podcast
bob wade and i
that is us our one two three bob
wade me we have a new podcast called
distractable
you may have heard of it but you may not
know that it's completely free and if
you go through the link in the
description below right down there right
there there's the link
click that click that link click it now
you'll go find distractible which is
completely free or you can go to spotify
and type in d-i-s-t-r-a-c-i-d-l-e and
you'll find distractible look
there's our cool icon or apple podcast
you can type in the same thing and
you'll find hey
there's distractible i would recommend
bob's fridge as your first episode
because it's a hilarious story about bob
getting a fridge delivered that did not
go well for him and he's angry about it
i'm waiting i find that very funny
and i think he will too all right now
back to the forest
bye okay well here's the sinkhole
there was a cave you did come out of a
cave i know that
was it on like the north side i see a
couple holes in the ground over here
yeah there definitely is a cave entrance
somewhere around the edge that gets you
into the into the network around the
sinkhole
okay apparently my map says i'm right on
top of a cave entrance but i'm not
seeing something
we could go with a bob strat and just
leap in and see what happens
ah how about we don't because i found a
cave right here this might be the
entrance
okay well that might be what we need
is there a door though because if
there's not a door i don't even
care him i'm gonna just try the cape
there's a hole goodbye
where the hell is the thing
is it is waiting can one of you go
towards oh hey
there we go oh my god it's sick oh i'm
falling i'm
falling i'm falling i'm in water
what oh maybe i don't go down this one
wait is this the same cave that we were
just in this is the same cave we were in
don't
don't fall down because it's the longest
ass climb in the world this is not the
cave
ah sorry i misled us i'm climbing this
one-handed holding a lighter i am so
strong
you are strongest boy
thanks guys thank you okay where are you
guys
around the whole left when you come out
okay also i'm gonna try to
get some more supplies in case we need
more mollies
there any suitcases here no is that you
mark running like a psychopath no hey
wait we have friends wait where are you
okay
help oh mark pinch maneuver
there's no suitcases here i'm on the way
two for one oh nope not two for one oh
need to block
owie that was half my health in one hit
mark we could really use a hand i'm on
the way
gosh guys i'm trying to like cover you
away but they're
circling i think i found the other cave
entrance by the way
good good good i'm coming to you duh uh
come to me come to me
uh where they're between us
all right why are you guys all the way
over there we were circling the thing
what do you mean
i don't know i'm just asking hey you
don't need to do it
i don't think so oh you guys are so far
away oh
there's one running towards you from us
i see that yeah that one's yours okay
i'll try to get him
well he's really fast they're really
fast guys yeah they're
so fast this they hurt
okay slice him up and he's down yeah
he's down
got him all right the cave was over here
talking to me it's right by this tent
here
ooh new item added to to-do list i hear
growling
well mark behind oh i see
go for the game go for the game
isn't this the same one no no this is
not the same one i swear to you are you
sure
it is not the same it looks the same
smells the same
is the same but it's not the same it's
not the same same
okay no that's not the same okay yeah
i've been here okay not the same
time not the same this looks like maybe
a rebreather cave and i don't have that
still
nah come on man
possible
no way no re-breathing
all right let me just take a scouting
no no it's it's down and up real quick
oh okay yeah it just goes straight down
hot dude i love
pot an america mask
gas wait or bob you'd remember oh yep
this is the place
ooh i would remember no
a hole it's bob's hole oh hey
i'm home it's bob's hole
lawyer my hole boobs and
boobs in medicine guys over here hell
yeah
yeah that is my language yeah
more dynamics i want boobs and candy
story thing i think these are flares
a nice photo of a tree love me a tree
x marks the spot at the tree did you see
that
uh i'm sure there's a treasure or
something oh this is pitch black in here
oh
soda lag hmm it's not much scarier than
the game that we've encountered than
this
it i would like to be cookie please
be funny oh okay it's fine it's fine
what is that
thing take some of this
all those babies are really doing kung
fu
yeah this guy's tough okay i'm walking
oh yeah i'm tanking
okay hitting i'm almost at stanford
trying to keep the
down go down go down knock it down go
down
go down oh my god go down there you go
there you go there no
oh my god went up hey come back here
come back here what are you doing oh
go down okay there oh my god
yeah there you go well that was wild
whoa um well that looks deep what the
hell is that
goodness gracious oh oh
not water
don't why would you think about it don't
see this little path off to the side
as well better jump and die yeah this is
clearly my only option
okay i'm gonna jump across but it looks
like is that but clearly your only
option
clearly chevrolet lower price is low
rates
you know that mark i don't know i don't
think yeah i really do say do you guys
have that up there
i thought that was not from ohio when
you remember
okay not that way remember i lived in
cincinnati for like a decade
oh remember that i forgot that you guys
used to
be you remember yeah you remember you
remember
okay should i go down just jump oh well
i wasn't gonna jump
you're the man with the map
well you oh yeah you don't have a map it
looks like just a lot of suitcases down
here there was another path
on the other side that might be the
correct way to go okay well that wasn't
worth it
i don't think so well so we can go back
up that rope that you have mark can we
go back up on the other side and
potentially
go more places um there might be
something there but also just like i
think that
that doesn't let you go anywhere else we
have to go back the way
there is another way up there you can go
up that way because i think there's a
story item there or something
wait where did they oh it's right here
yeah
yeah check that out see if there's
something you're curious what mark's ass
would look like on a rope now you know
oh is it good very good
thanks the lighting was better it's p
good yeah thanks
guys there's a cassette tape player uh
oh because that tape over here
uh-huh is it worth going over there
that's it baby
because i don't think you can get out of
that spot is this not the place where
the
climbing thing happens no there's one
more over here
oh you're like in one of the pits that
we had to jump over it looks like
wait wait wait wait what
wait what there's a climbing axe over
here wait
what yeah there's a rope right here how
did we get down to the
cave bob do you remember it all how you
got down to the
the actual pit itself no i don't know if
i actually got to the bottom of the pit
i just sort of
fell down the side and then found a way
up at some point
so i don't remember seeing this but i do
remember getting the climbing axe but
it's
it's just like i don't remember there
being a big open left
place there you know what i mean
i see what you did and i'm gonna climb
this real quick and just if it's a cave
exit then i know we went the wrong way
yeah yeah climbing wall i think this is
just the way
out this is not right we're going the
wrong way this can't be right
all right going back down this is
strange i feel like there's something to
do with that big
uh drop off there there might have been
like another way down
old gun ammo and a robot or not
oh wait what is that wait i'm looking at
the map i see something
back you guys keep going forward i'm
gonna i'm gonna go back a bit
explore i'm looking back by where the
pit opens up
to see if like there's a another way
down or something
it doesn't look like i'm though yeah i
guess bob you didn't fall all the way
down did you you fell
kind of the way down right yeah
okay let me pop in four different ways
three or four different ways to go here
there's got to be like a destructible
wall or something like that
that we're not seeing because i i would
believe that's how all these connections
there must be something down in that
water
big water pit okay that's my other
thought there's got to be something down
there right
what if we just parkour down from right
here
uh i don't think that's a good idea but
you can try it
bob did you ever go further down than
this i don't remember actually
i bet we could get all the way down
there you bet
you want to try that is this the is this
the end of the forest no matter what
happens
[Applause]
all right do it who's a brave jumper i'm
gonna i'm gonna
try this
i'm gonna try this i'm trying to save
the world no
we haven't no all right oh it's fine
up here
yeah so far so good seems okay so far
kind of like a way to rub around the
edges here
get down here yeah so far so i'm pretty
sure this house was supposed to happen
i mean they shouldn't have made it so
sloped if they didn't want anyone
sloping down them
definitely don't go that way does that
hurt
okay oh owie careful i believe in you
wade i think you have the right path
stung a little bit but i'm feeling all
right oh that's big
oh hey there's a dude down here hey i'm
making molly's i guess
yeah don't don't go all the way in hey
guys you guys want to stand on top of
stuff and not go in there
yeah definitely yeah 100.
great we do have the chainsaws do you
remember that i don't think you can
climb up here so
oh wait i got an angle on him let me
just see how would you say that
out loud with your words
bam i don't think he can come up here
i'm a dynamite dino mito
[Music]
bam right on him oh my god a really nice
um
on the chainsawing oh god
just die there we go okay okay
okay i don't think they can come up here
i don't think they got i don't think i
can come up there
let's just keep chucking molly's i only
got one left just be ready in case
another one decides to make a
pop-up hello yay oh almost hit the fade
away
i have a fair amount of mollies okay
he's really tucked in there let me see
if i can get him
yes i got him yeah oh that's not dead
just got back up
that guy was not dead i have a bow but i
don't have a lot of arrows i have
i have arrows i can give you arrows damn
it's bright
wait just holding the chainsaw and not
using it still use gas i don't know i
don't know
can you see the big o mark yeah it's
from my angle i see it directly
yeah come on get get the angle on this
one i think maybe it's trying to hit me
so i'll just
stay down here he's directly under that
rock there you can see him from there oh
yeah
yeah i'll keep him up here
just don't miss and hit me i probably
won't do that
uh for some reason that the normal dudes
or quote-unquote normal dudes have
decided to all be in a pile over on the
right side over there
and i don't know why nice molly
be my own very angry can you make
throwing spears or something how do you
make a spear you can throw spears you
just
hold right click and then uh
left click and you'll like chuck the
spear
i'm afraid of popping down because of
those three dudes we might be able to
pop down and chainsaw this guy the rest
of the way
well there's there's so many other dudes
that i'm afraid yeah i know
let's see if i can hack a dynamite yeah
that'd be good try that
there we go coming over that's
nice did you get it i'm throwing another
dynamite because there's like a pile of
them
come here you're good whoops well that
throw didn't do so good
dynamite coming in hot boys that's
another nice one oh that was a good one
oh he's up here oh my god oh my god i'm
getting hit oh my god
oh he's down he's got down he's kicked
out okay good taking a medicine jeez
i think you guys there's two down there
okay we might be able to take them
but i mean i can't i'm uh i'm
slingshotting them right now
okay good i tried to do it yeah i might
try to just get in the corner we're
doing this
i think so wait wait wait there's a big
chunk over to the left
be careful okay are you dead careful
that one over here under me coming for
him walk into my tank probably
big big baby is big moving
[Applause]
i'm not doing this completely not
stopping wait that's the direction that
the big baby guy is
okay he's over there on the other side
of those rocks oh but i parked up on a
rock
good job good job you're excellent at
this you're excellent
oh that is a big one there's two two
babies two babies two big babies two of
them
take it back up on this one oh i can
yes what's up
[ __ ] come on world of warcraft
climbing skills don't fail me now there
we go
oh dude look at my spot over here that's
a good killing it
that's a quality spot okay i see one
where's the other
tucked up under the rock right in front
of wade whoa something just blew up
all right i got one lit okay that's good
i'm like completely out
of uh of molly's so i might have to just
be brave
there is a body of water here that i
might try to bait him into
nice chuck that get them both
oh god oh god i'm hooking another one
uh your direction mark okay all right
i'm gonna go for the water
going for the water come for me in the
water you can never come
i lit i lit the one that's not with you
come on oh i think we both did come on
come on come on what is that oh there's
more over here
there's more be careful where you go
there's more
hair oh my god there are where are we
supposed to go is the question
i don't [ __ ] know we probably need to
explore the helicopter that we just uh
yeah i could try let me go over there
and just see what's up
just before we leave don't move don't
move don't move
god oh it went through the floor there's
like a direct hit
um do we try chainsawing these guys can
we stun them
they cannot be stunned i don't think
they're very unstable
they love to kick okay i see nothing on
the helicopter
anything in the helicopter i am inside
the helicopter i hope i'm not stuck in
the helicopter
i might be stuck in the helicopter which
would be terrible
i am stuck in the helicopter
no i can get out can i
oh no i'm out no i'm out
oh what is that oh what is that
oh my god the horrible noises guys come
over here
guys come over here what's up buddy um
this door just opened here oh [ __ ]
it's not open for me it's open for me
i'm coming um coming
all right put on a business suit look at
me you got a business suit nice
oh wait was that in the helicopter i
want one oh i kind of
saw that thing all right oh hey i didn't
hit the machete yet did you guys grab
the machete i got the machete
no where's that right in the helicopter
we mean business bob yeah mark
you don't look very serious come here
right you're right you're right i need
to go
where'd you find it on the other side
very nice very very nice i can put rocks
on this
offering table dude sick offering
it probably opens the door
oh that makes sense
oh
okay this just leads to a cave this
might have been the correct way in
i don't think we should go back out yeah
i think we got to fight those dudes how
do you make a slingshot i forget
can i make that slingshot duct tape
cloth yeah
i can't okay i can i'll i'll try to
slingshot some stuff
i mean probably i'm gonna switch back to
the chain software go fight those big
dudes
oh you guys don't like that not on fire
again
oh [ __ ] no no there's no way they healed
right
oh wait oh my god wade he went over the
rock
he sure did he sure did my dude i don't
think that they stunned me careful
oh my god be careful oh i don't want it
in here anymore
i don't even know what i'm doing i'm
trying now
oh he ran oh there oh wait what did you
do
fascinating fascinating
chopping chopping oh my god shopping as
hard as i can oh they're both here
they're both here
guys in a hole you're stuck in a hole
getting you up i don't think they can
hit me from here but i'm stuck in here
you're stuck right here where we can
build you something to get out of there
well there's no logs down here but
i'm down here underneath one of them in
a crevice
okay all right okay
that's okay that's an interesting thing
i think i'm safe but oh i see you guys
[ __ ] yeah i see your name now oh
maybe you could eventually punch you out
of the way there oh yeah
oops well my aim is bad you going in
with
i'm joining you oh my god
oh jesus that hurts a lot
okay bob i'm gonna try to where are you
i'm in the middle of these rocks i don't
know if i can actually get out of this
okay maybe try crouch jumping
oh i see where you are okay um let's see
oh wait okay okay okay yeah yeah kind of
like jump and strafe at the same time
and then like side
rotate your mouse left and right oh
incoming wade
oh my god i might have i got out
i might have just fallen in the hole
with you oh god no i didn't oh god we're
not fine let's just run past him to
wherever we need to go maybe
whoa good i'm going in the water i'm
going in the water oh i just got plowed
again
i'm i'm water shaped crevice oh no
oh god all right i need to go get away
stand up
i need to get weighed yeah i'm gonna try
and uh
oh god nope i'm going down in the
crevice oh my god i got hit
on the way down i'm trying to get you
let me get you oh please let me get him
okay i feel great good you should [ __ ]
are we i don't know oh you guys are in
the hole
in the hole it's fine we'll get out of
the hole you got out we can get up
okay i got out i'm going in the water
wait the other way towards the water was
an easier way to get out there
yeah i don't know if they drown too but
if they can if we can get them to charge
into the water that may be our only hope
hmm come here stinkies okay screw those
guys
you said there were a bunch more people
over this way right over this way
there's another group yeah
yeah maybe now that they're on the other
side of the water we might be away from
them enough
maybe i wish i could see time for the
flashlight
oh well i don't so this looks like
normies over here
yeah where's the door where's the
goddamn door
is that a way down this is i don't think
so
it looks like it should be something
though didn't it all right then buy
these boxes
it must be the next place oh well [ __ ]
there's all the dudes
that's okay if we can get them up here
one at a time or something
you good down there bob yeah careful
there it is
i'm gonna join you i'm going bob this
big one's coming big one's coming oh big
one's coming big one's coming oh my god
big one's coming
bob get out of there
[Music]
oh go to the water to the water ooh to
the water
but they're not coming up okay they're
not coming up maybe we can get them from
no that one's coming up all right oh
yeah they're all they're up there oh my
god i'm getting chained
oh my god i'm getting chained up
oh
[Music]
oh my god i'm down i got him
okay you're good i'm going to run around
with the rocks let me see if i can draw
them away at least
there's a lot of boxes down there i
don't know if they're a big one big ones
in the water
big ones not deep enough but it's in the
water
okay there's a lot of boxes down here
uh it's dead i think it drowned ooh well
hell yeah
i don't see where they're going there's
a little one chilling down here there's
a lot of boxes
i'm tempted
um
what
guys i got i got hoes these boxes aren't
good they're dead
they're dead we're good
that's nice oh these boxes are all bad
these boxes are dumb is there a campfire
down here i am [ __ ] cold
oh wait this one has players okay
oh was this all bust well
looks like we've reached the end
of a [ __ ] get to the bottom of the pit
i mean we finished it
we did it guys we really did